the draft goat draft week 13 goats in a
bad way draft Chris I have the trivia
question the answer today is not Jim
Turner I'm still upset about yesterday
Hubie thought me I don't hold a grudge
here we got shut up just shut up
here we go Russell Wilson now has the
best winning percentage of any
quarterback in Monday Night Football
history with 81 point eight percent
which quarterback did he surpass last
night and I'll give you a hint okay
he's retired and he's not in the Hall of
Fame he's retired and not in the Hall of
Fame damn that really hurt me whoa he's
not phil simms yeah I almost went there
for a second he's retired and not in the
Hall of Fame I have no idea I can't even
think who did playing the NFC East at
one point he did play in the NFC East at
one point Donovan McNabb you're getting
a lot of hits here I know you get a lot
of head I'm interest rate up Cunningham
Oh Cunningham Randall was well I know
against my dad and the Giants back in
the day he was a pain in the butt with
that defense and him making plays man I
used to love Randall Cunningham quick
story I had one year at the quarterback
challenge Mike I was so obsessed with
Randall Cunningham I was a young kid I
followed him around everywhere I mean
literally I was obsessed with them and
like to the point where I was following
him to his room at night and he was like
hey kid get the hell out of here go to
bed I'm going to sleep but awesome and
he's always be a legend to me sorry yeah
I mean and he had that year out of
football when he was working in Las
Vegas installing kitchen countertops
right right came back to the Vikings is
back up and then he had that 98 season
magical MVP consideration got a new
contract it ended up falling apart for
him in 99 he was a backup for several
years after that but had a great run in
the NFL so good Russell Wilson passes
Randall Cunningham there's your answer
the trivia question the answer to my
question is who's my first-round pick
now that I've I've won the question by
default lines I got to go Fredi kitchens
yeah Freddie kitchens the Browns yeah
head coach look the the Pittsburgh
started a t-shirt
not a good look the fact that multiple
Steelers players said after the game
that they were motivated by it that it
was bulletin board material for them not
good it's it's it feels like it's
crumbling for Freddie
kitchens that was a huge game if they
win that game they're six and six the
Steelers are six and six different vibe
going down the stretch
now the browns are five and seven
they're gonna have a very hard time
making the postseason we're gonna have a
hard time having a better record they
had last year they got some games coming
up they should be able to win they get
the Bengals twice but they just need to
focus they need to try to win the next
four if they could finish nine and seven
maybe that gives them some hope going
into next year but Freddie it's on
Freddie kitchens for Sunday and it could
be that Freddie kitchens ends up one and
done like I you know we've seen plenty
of coaches over the years you people
think it's rare it's not that rare and
Freddie could be the next one yeah no I
mean that's not a good look for what
happened last week I mean just you know
again like Freddie's a guy like but this
is just kind of adds to the talk around
whether Freddie is prepared for the job
and they just you know again a head
coach wearing that shirt and a sensitive
topic and a big rivalry I mean just come
on you got to know you're the head coach
it's not really a big deal in everyday
life but it's a big deal in football
world and it's just something you
shouldn't do as the head coach when the
microscope is on you on a weekend week
out basis and of course it's on
Cleveland right now and him and the team
and how they've underperformed and all
that so I'm with you that was a pretty
bonehead move and deserves to be in the
draft all right I'm gonna go with Nick
Foles yeah I gotta put him in the go
draft I mean come on you know he gets
brought into Jacksonville to kind of be
the savior therefore Blake bortles it
has not been good and the last three
weeks have been really borderline
disaster they haven't even been able to
be competitive in a football game so
it's not even like it there's nothing to
look at right now and go positive you
heard me say earlier I mean he can't
move well in the pocket his arm looks
average he's made bad decisions he's had
bad awareness of what's around him in
the pocket I think that's the most
troubling thing you know I mean some of
some of these sack fumbles he had during
the game I mean he's dead that one there
you know people are gonna go whoa that
wasn't his fault you know he started to
go backwards in the pocket this one they
know he's moving in the pocket yeah
they're coming after you secure the ball
so yeah he's goat in a bad way this week
yeah who has goat in a bad way get out
of here go get it you say goats just we
have to say bad way because every week
you think oh it's goats in a good way
and it's
like a little tongue-in-cheek thing yeah
it's the go travel all right we don't
want to make the list you're gonna make
the list if you keep it up I'm gonna go
with Jim Schwartz the Eagles defensive
coordinator an idea inspired by you and
conversations we had about the inability
to cover
Devante Parker on Sunday a fairly
important game for the Eagles and I've
supported Jim Schwartz getting head
coaching consideration a couple of years
ago I was surprised that the Giants
didn't give him a look-see when they
were replacing Ben McAdoo but Sunday's
performance by the Eagles defense in
Miami will do nothing to get Schwartz on
anyone's a good list yeah they didn't
react they didn't adjust they didn't do
anything they let Devante Parker shet I
shred them all game long and look I know
they don't have a great secondary but
you could double the guy yeah you could
use that's the point to try to you could
take him away do something they did
nothing they just kept daring him to
beat them and guess what he kept beating
them yeah no you're right that's what
I'd like to it would have liked to seen
and Jim Schwartz has been really good
this year I mean you know they let up
some points early in the year when they
were banged up and injured and then you
know really as of late have played
phenomenal football and then just lay an
absolute egg against the Miami Dolphins
and I think your points very real like
hey Mike Zimmer he does what he does
right he's oh this is my defense and he
doesn't change it a lot but when he got
to the end of the Denver game and the
Dallas Cowboy game he doubled Amari
Cooper and Courtland Sutton because they
were killing him he said I'm not gonna
let them beat us you know at some point
during that game yes I would have liked
to have seen Jim Schwartz go all right
this guy is absolutely shredding us
today I'm not gonna let him beat us in
this moment right here you know Ryan
Fitzpatrick is gonna have to go to
somebody else and he he had a field day
as in Devante Parker all right Derek
Carr will be my next one you know I
tried to defend Derek Carr a little last
week in the New York Jets game because
there was some big drops and some big
moments and all of that but you know yes
Aaron Sunday in that game you know the
interceptions he threw and again I'm not
a stat reader they were big in the in
the the moment of it was big I mean hey
it's the first time you've had the ball
and you throw an out route and really
throw it like you it's predetermined
like oh I saw this coverage all along
and hi this should be open well you know
there's players on the field and you got
to see throws and the throw will pick
that early against Tyrann Mathieu and
then all of a sudden BAM you're down
seven nothing the defense is kind of
hanging in there and keeping in its
14-nothing and then you throw a pick six
because you kind of just go well all
week this play was open against his
coverage I'm gonna throw it well the
human beings know you were gonna throw
that too and that was disappointing so
he put them in a hole early on that they
just could not overcome
who's the starting quarterback week 1
2020 for the Las Vegas Raiders oh gosh I
don't know but I mean you're you're
right that's a real question I mean in
John Gordon's history and everything
I've seen and been around and the way
Derek Carr has not exactly blown us away
it's been a good year not a great year
yeah I would think John's gonna lose
gonna flirt with some people in the
offseason you know it he's a 40 guy when
it comes to quarterbacks
you know he is he's in the flirt with
some draft picks he's gonna flirt with
some free agents either way I think at
the very least if they don't just
supplant him there's gonna be a guy
that's in there that's gonna be
breathing down his neck this year I
think that's the thing you'll see more
than anything he's gonna bring
competition in there I gotta get on to
my pick but if there was a board
somewhere with all the odds of who is
most likely to be the Raiders starting
quarterback last year and I'm not saying
that that this person should be high on
the list he would be a long shot but I'd
be tempted to put a Sawbuck on Andrew
Luck as the starting quarterback of the
LA and the laws are talking about of
80/20 yeah yeah and who could talk him
out of it better than Jon Gruden
it'd be relentless that would be yeah oh
no let's stop right right no state
income tax and look what we can do and
you're a smart guy and you're a big guy
and all it would be and I'm tell you
what the Raiders the Raiders would be a
lot better with Andrew Luck as their
quarterback next year all right for me
round 3 hate to do it because I love the
guy he's great for the NFL but Jerry
Jones you get the goat horns this week
all that stuff about Jason Garrett being
in trouble that was clearly a ploy to
try to will the team to a victory on
Thanksgiving against the bills and it
didn't work they didn't respond it ended
up being a failure and end up being a
disaster
he didn't mean it right if he meant it
he would have fired him after that game
and and it was it was a misguided effort
to talk the team to a victory and it
just didn't work and and at this point
he's quieted down since then
you know what's the deck Prescott's a
talk is cheap we got to get away from
this constant discussion and speculation
and I know that Jerry Jones attitude is
any publicity is good publicity and he
he does two radio spots a week and I'll
probably do one today in Dallas but but
I just think that enough and last week
it was I believe a calculated effort to
try to put a red-hot poker on to Jason
Garrett's rear end and it didn't work
and now they're they're stuck and the
only good news for the Cowboys is the
Eagles lost yeah yeah it's you know I
hear you it's it's hard to argue I think
there was better ones out there and
that's why I'll win the draft right here
but the Dallas Cowboys everyday anyways
um hmm I'm not sure here I mean I want
to pick the Panthers front seven for
beginning absolutely shellacked against
the Redskins and a team that can't throw
the ball but I'm not gonna do that I'm
gonna go down to old Chris Simms ville
and pick a whole entire organization
you kind of did that right now you took
Jerry Jones which is a taking the old
cowboy team now it's not yeah it is yeah
he's the owner distraction that
contributed to the loss on Thanksgiving
Chargers team okay I'm taking them all
the coaches the players the owners every
one of them that was the most damnedest
Chargers loss ever I mean I've never
seen anything like the Chargers you know
three just cuz you picked him to win and
I picked the Broncos is that why you're
upset
oh no I'm really not and I totally
forgot that but this three to the last
four years I've never seen a team find
so many different ways to lose football
games in crazy fashion I mean this one
Phillip Rivers dumb interception early a
muffed punt I mean they had that and set
up a short field I mean gets drew lock
who hasn't played football since you
know late December last year it's his
first NFL start and then to rally
back and hey listen the pass
interference call I think was a little
bit questionable what's still you know
there was other issues with that play
and how it was defended down the end
anyways and to lose that way it was just
the most Chargers loss ever and just
disheartening for a team that continues
to fight but seems to screw it up on a
weekly basis
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports